schnell ans ziel mit diesem roten
flitzer
das ist möglich aber leider nicht legal
absolut nicht legal
[Musik]
die aufnahmen sind auf einer autobahn in
tschechien entstanden
vermutlich haben sich die anderen
verkehrsteilnehmer ziemlich gewundert
der wagen ein rennbolide aus der formel
2 rennserie eine art nachwuchs liga der
formel 1 das auto entspricht natürlich
nicht der straßenverkehrsordnung und
deswegen sucht die polizei nun nach dem
fahrer der war aber offenbar so schnell
wieder weg dass ihn die beamten erst in
den sozialen medien bemerkt haben
2009 10 war etwas ziemlich
vergleichbares passiert ein ganz
ähnlicher rote rennwagen rausch durch
tschechien die polizei konnte den wagen
nach aufwendige ermittlungsarbeit
lokalisieren der mutmaßliche fahrer
allerdings nicht zuverlässig
identifiziert werden weil er wie in den
rennserien vorgeschrieben einen helm auf
hatte
[Musik]